hey
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and i'm so happy we get
to do this one more time sony have just
dropped our first look at the end of the
spider verse sequel and throughout this
video we're going to be breaking it down
giving our thoughts on it and also
talking about everything you need to
know about the movie there might be some
spoilers here so if you want to go into
the movie without knowing anything then
i miss the part where that's my problem
don't forget to give us a thumbs up and
also make sure you subscribe for videos
like this every day without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into our breakdown okay so the
upcoming movie is judo released on
october 7th 2022 though the film is
still shrouded in mystery there are a
lot of things that we can piece together
from the clues that we've been given the
movie has been worked on for three years
now and you might remember that we
actually got a teaser video for it all
the way back in november 2019. it's wild
thinking about all the stuff that's
happened since then in this decade worst
decade ever and just as a quick
refresher of that it basically showed
logos that teased all the versions of
spider-man that could be showing up this
included miles morales potentially
spirit spider the 90s cartoon one penny
parker silk japanese spider-man secret
wars spider gwen who will be voiced by
hayley steinfeld ben reilly who you'll
probably know as being a clone of peter
parker and spider-man 2099 now if you
cast your mind back to the ending of the
last movie then you'll probably remember
that it involved miguel o'hara aka
spider-man 2099 using a device that
actually allowed him to travel through
the multiverse he visited the 1960s
timeline so i actually think that he
might be the one who pulls everyone
together in the first film everyone was
glitching out and this meant that they
had a countdown on them but if he's got
a device that stops this it'll allow
them to interact without having to worry
about that most sequels tend to forget
the rules set up in the first movie
which is why we've had like 10
terminator films even though they said
no more time traveling in the first one
so i do kind of hope that they have a
device that just stops all that
glitching and my bitching now i think
this is gonna be the case is that in the
first look we can see gwen wearing this
when she enters miles room this can be
made out on her wrist and it would also
explain how she's able to jump across
the spider verse at will when we go to
the action shot from the first look we
can also catch spiderman 2099 busting in
our 2 as he catches miles and jumps
across into another reality the device
says 928 and just in case you don't know
earth's in the marvel universe are given
designations like this for example the
main timeline is 616 but other realities
are divided up into other numbers in the
comics earth 928 is actually a possible
feature of earth 616 which is broken out
into a war between humans and mutants
though the mutants had all all the cool
powers in this reality the humans
actually won because we're number one
now this reality is also the home of
spider-man 2099 so it makes sense that
he'd travel here first as it's his home
now i really hope that this reality pops
up more in the movie and it's not just
somewhere that we hop through like the
one that precedes it i think if it does
then averting this war could end up
being one of the plot points in the film
with it being a possible future a
spider-man from the future aka miguel
could end up showing miles this reality
before making it clear to him why they
have to do everything in their power to
stop this from coming to fruition
however going beyond that it could be
taking place post-war which is when
spider-man 2099 really rose to power and
he set out on a mission to stop dr doom
who could end up becoming the film's
main villain now the clip itself starts
right where into the spider-verse ended
with spider-gwen opening up a portal
between her earth and miles's we
actually get the classic meanwhile in
another universe text transitioning into
gwen's colors during the scene to
foreshadow her dropping into his room
this clip was actually shown at
comic-con xp in brazil and the creative
team behind it said that though this
takes place immediately after the events
of the first movie there's actually been
a year between the plot of that film and
this one this is why miles actually
looks slightly older than he did in into
the spider-verse which i think is a
really nice touch he's also back at home
and you might remember that in the last
film he had a dorm room which also
explains how he's able to get grounded i
think it's hilarious how all the stuff
from his room is floating around above
his head and he grabs his tighty whities
to hide them from gwen behind here we
can see the hexagonal shape that later
pops up as a tunnel when miles travels
across the multiverse and as we know
from one division hexagons are very
important they were also used in films
like guardians of the galaxy and captain
marvel to display where a jump point is
so i love that the movie has brought
them back here as they're basically a
building block of the universe now as we
jump into the scene we can see a comic
book floating around and this has miles
face on it with a tagline save the
multiverse now what comics were of
course used in the first movie to film
backstories and i love that miles now
has his own one at the panel the
creative team said that miles has just
discovered how lonely is keeping the
secret about who he is from the people
he loves which i definitely feel is
hinted at in this title now as gwen
drops in we can also catch a photo of
miles and his uncle aaron who of course
died in the last movie aaron was the
prowler and he very much provided miles
with an uncle ben type origin story that
inspired him to go on to be bigger and
better now in this scene gwen is very
much recruiting miles to go on a big
mission with her across the multiverse
and there are other hints to many spider
people showing up in this room for
example we get a lot of japanese
iconography such as a pokemon card that
flips around and on top of his chest of
drawers we can also catch a mech
japanese spider-man actually has his own
mech and you can also spot some power
ranger type figures just below them we
can also catch the spider-mobile from
the comics which hopefully means we're
getting some form of the 616 version
back like a peter b parker gwen opens
miles sketchbook up and inside of it she
sees a sketch of herself however going
beyond that we can also catch a bus
ticket which i believe is the one that
peter and miles bought in the movie when
traveling out to the science lab gwen
tries to get miles to come with her by
saying that he's grounded but spider-man
isn't from here we transition into
spider-man traveling through the
multiverse showing that she got him she
got you a punk and we also see that he
has a slightly different suit and
instead of having webbing on it this one
doesn't i do kind of like the webbing on
the first one but i like this design as
well and maybe they just kept the render
simpler for the computers as we're going
to be getting a lot of spider people now
this movie is going to be titled across
the spider verse and that's because
miles will be going across the spider
verse into other realities instead of
just staying in his own now it's not too
long after before miles drops into a
universe that we don't learn too much
about but there are indeed some clues
there as miles falls we get some brief
texts pop up and shout sunil shah for
confirming that this is hindi as he goes
further into the world we can also catch
someone on a billboard and it is
possible that this is hinting towards
spider-man india popping up at some
point however we don't spend that much
time in this reality as miguel o'hara
shows up and then grabs miles i love how
the sound effects are hindi too and even
though this pops up on screen for less
than a second it shows how much
attention to detail the animators were
putting into the film from here we jump
into 928 and there's a lot of spanish
writing on all the signs and miguel
himself is half irish and half mexican
so i really like this touch i absolutely
love the way that miguel webs onto miles
and he almost has an omega beam-like
webbing to his design here it just looks
so cool and it's great watching them
jump across from dimension to dimension
i actually have a theory that in this
scene miles ended up getting lost in the
multiverse as we can see that he doesn't
have a device on his wrist perhaps this
was taken from him or something but if i
had to hazard a guess i'd say that
miguel is probably saving him from being
lost in another reality and he's
launching a rescue attempt to bring him
into his universe so that they can put
their plan together to stop whatever's
going on it's an awesome first look and
i really enjoyed getting up at 3am this
morning to do this video for you even
though you won't bloody thumbs up it
will you god i hate you
now as for my thoughts on the movie i'm
so hyped and that first film was an
absolute classic so i can't wait to
watch this next one when i first saw it
i did quite enjoy it but i think over
time it's actually gotten better and
better and even better that movie is an
absolute classic and i'm really hoping
that they can recapture what made that
first film so good and if they add in
all these other versions of spider-man
it's going to be something amazing i
think into the spider-verse really
inspired marvel to start opening up the
multiverse and it's definitely
influenced a lot of the future
directions that franchises are going i
can't wait to watch it and obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on the brand
new look so make sure you comment below
and let me know we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the spider-man 4k
trilogies on the 30th of december and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the first look we pick the comments
at random at the end of the month and
the winners of the last one on screen
right now serve that to you then message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers if you
want some else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of hawkeye
which will be linked on screen right now
we went over everything in episode three
and gave our fan theory on who uncle is
so make sure you check it out right
after this without the way thank you for
singing through the video i mean paul
let's see on the next one take care
peace